hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well near the end of
book six of his Republic Plato has
Socrates as his mouthpiece set out and
extended analogy and he uses that word
there Anna logia between two things one
of them is very well known to us it is
the Sun that illuminates our world and
which gives it most if not all of its
energy that we rely upon without even
thinking about and the second is what he
calls the form of the good or actually
in this part of the work he talks about
it as the Calonne out tone and Agathon
out home the good in the sense of the
beautiful in itself the the beautiful as
such and the good as such and these are
not understood as two different things
or even two different aspects of it this
is what it means to be the form of the
good and the form of the good he says is
like the Sun or rather if you want to
understand it properly the Sun itself is
like the form of the good and it's
actually in a certain sense and
offspring and he uses the word there for
biological offspring meaning that
that somehow the form of the good gave
rise to gave birth to created however we
want to conceptualize this because Plato
himself doesn't tell us here gave rise
to the Sun and he says that the Sun
exists in this sort of analogy this this
extended set of relationships with the
form of the good so by looking at the
relationship between the Sun and other
things we can better understand the
truer reality of the form of the good
and its relationship with the soul and
what Plato calls the intelligible world
of the forms or the ideas which are more
real than the visible tangible material
things that we encounter so what can we
say about the Sun and first Plato goes
into a little bit of a distinction
between sight and the other senses
hearing he says doesn't actually require
some sort of other medium so that one
may hear and the other be heard of
course we know that it does because
hearing takes place through sound waves
but we can put that aside very clear
that sight does require more than just
the capacity in our eyes or whatever our
apparatus is that's making sight work
you know the ocular nerve and the brain
centers it requires more than that to
actually have sight not to have sight in
the sense of having the sense but for
the sense to actually do anything for us
to see anything there have to be some
other conditions first there has to be
something for us to actually see if we
were in some sort of void we wouldn't
need to exercise our Faculty of sight
but even more important than that for
Plato is having the Sun and you know you
might object of course
well what about artificial light and
you know couldn't you do without the Sun
and you know there's also infrared light
and things like that
yes but all of that radiant energy
although it may not have originally come
just from our Sun in the way that we
understand things cosmologically now
certainly came from somewhere and you
can analogize that to our Sun but if you
put yourself back in Plato's perspective
and think about where all of the energy
in our world originates from all the
things that can provide us with a
certain kind of luminosity it all comes
for him from the Sun the Sun is what
gives rise to generation and heat and
light and all of these things that make
us possible for us to see visible things
and he notes to as well that when we're
in the broad light of the Sun and we're
looking at things provided our vision is
is working properly we can see the
visible things quite clearly we can
distinguish them from each other we know
what they are we can figure out how to
use them to move around them we could
look at our own bodies we can get around
in the world
however when we're looking at things he
says in darkness or in shadow or even
just by the light of the stars and the
moon as opposed to the light of the Sun
then we don't see quite so distinctly we
might mistake things for each other I'll
give you an example of that I used to
work as a security guard second and
third shift and when you're looking at
things in the light that's cast by
street lamps not the Sun sometimes you
mix things up a bush may look like a
deer a stick may look like a snake you
could add all sorts of things in there
your eyes start to play tricks on you
and Plato knew that that was the case as
well so in order for our Faculty of
vision to work correctly we need the
combination of the Sun the Sun
illuminates the visible things and it
allows our sight to take in those
visible things and make sense of them
the other thing that he says is we can
also turn our gaze towards the Sun now
you can't look at the Sun very long and
I advise you not to try to do that for
more than a few moments but you
certainly can look at the source of
illumination and say aha
there it is and you can also think about
you know when it goes behind a cloud or
anything along those lines you can pay
attention to that so that's the visible
side of this analogy what about the
other side what about the intelligible
domain that Plato thinks is much more
real much more true than the visible
material world that's merely a set of
copies of the intelligible things and
world what corresponds to the Faculty of
sight in this case something like sight
for the soul the human mind if you like
if you don't like the theological
overtones of soul but if you do like
soul the soul is something immaterial
incorporeal and it's able to grasp
things that go beyond or rather that
transcend and provide the very
intelligibility and meaning to the
phenomenal world that we can see smell
touch and encounter in that way so once
again we come back to the form of the
good the form of the good is like the
Sun and in in some ways it's more
sun-like than the Sun he says that the
soul is able to grasp the intelligible
world it's able to know it it's able to
you might say wrap its mind around it
and it does this by virtue of the fact
that the intelligible world the things
within it are more true this is where he
says truth actually appears being torn
there's more being in the intelligible
world in the forms in the ideas then
there is in the visible things that we
can see which are at best mere copies of
those intelligible things so this is
quite important he actually uses three
terms here in it he says that we can
grasp it we can know it and in a certain
sense we at least appear to have
sometimes translated as understanding or
intellection or reason the word is noose
mind we we appear to have an
intellectual grasp on those intelligible
things by contrast but similar to when
we're trying to look at things in the
dark when we look at the world of coming
to be and going out of existence the
world of change the world of becoming
the world that is this entire visible
realm over here when we're directing our
attention our mental faculties to that
we don't actually see as clearly at best
he says we a pine those things we have
opinions about them
we have suppositions we look at how they
appear but we don't truly have knowledge
about those things even though we might
think that we do the only thing we can
have knowledge of in a strict sense is
the forms in the intelligible world and
the thing or the whatever it is form of
the good which provide them as Plato
says provides them with the very truth
that they have so
the things of the intelligible world
they have a greater truth than the
things of the material world but what is
giving them that truth is the form of
the good and he goes further he says the
form of the good gives the soul it's
very capacity to apprehend truth this is
not something that we think very much
about this is not something that most
people devote any attention to and yet
it's going on all the time insofar as we
are grasping the forms in the way that
Plato thinks about them at all it is
through the agency of the form of the
good making us capable of grasping those
things and giving those things they're
very intelligibility they're truth
they're being all that they have so the
Sun is really just a distance reflection
of the form of the good our Faculty of
sight is just a distant reflection of
the soul and its own capacity for for
understanding and knowing and the
material things that we might look at is
only a dim reflection of the
intelligible world of the forms Plato
brings us to a close by talking about a
few other very important things he says
that this reality that gives the truth
to the object of knowledge and the power
of knowing to the knower you must say is
the idea of good you must conceive it as
being the cause of knowledge and of
truth insofar is known and then he says
knowledge and truth those are wonderful
things are they not says fair as they
are as beautiful as those two things are
knowledge and truth in supposing it to
be something fair still than these you
will think rightly of it you will
understand what the form of the good or
the form of the beautiful is it's beyond
knowledge and truth which are themselves
already great so he says
as far as for knowledge and truth even
in an hour illustration it is right to
deem light and vision sun-like but never
to think that they are the Sun so here
it is right to consider these two their
counterparts as being like the good or
bona form that is formed like the good
but to think that either of them is the
good is not right knowledge is not the
good as such truth is not the good as
such but rather the form of the good is
the good as such and just as we're able
to look to the Sun and grasp it to some
degree and just as we rely upon the Sun
we as souls as immaterial minds whatever
you want to call them can grasp the form
of the good at least to the capacity at
least to the degree that we are able to
do so
you